I live
20 reps a day I live waste do it every
day
[Music]
then I go again I lift weights it's my
damn life I live waste do it every night
do it every day protein shakes
pre-workout I don't really play Everyday
I live every day I live I'm just
addicted I just do this I live
waste I stay strong creatine shakes yeah
that's what I'm on Creatine life
the way
I lift weights yeah I'm just strong yeah
yeah yeah punch you in your face I lift
weights no I don't fight that's lift
weights can you be all right yeah I got
muscles Lifeline struggle I'm just out
here lift the weights what lift the
waist hustle lift the weights double put
it on my plate
[Music]
know who I am know what I see biceps
triceps that's just my life I just lift
weights every damn night I waste I don't
sleep yeah I rest but it's just for me
well I rest but I don't sleep but I
sleep sometimes when I don't sleep I
lift weights then I just stop then I
never stop then I'm just stoned there's
no waste then I just get got this yeah
that's what I live I live ways you don't
live waste you should live waste I live
waste not giving advice but maybe you
should look at me look everything's good
that's why the flow's so strong you can
hear I live ways
[Music]
please
[Applause]
this way
[Music]